الهجوم بالمسيرات المفخخه على احدى قطع
البحريه الروسيه في البوسفور يذكر بهجمات
مماثله استهدفت منشات ومواقع عسكريه اما
في عمق الاراضي الروسيه او خارجها منذ
بدايه الحرب في اوكرانيا فبراير 2022
ميناء سيباستي بول الميناء الرئيسي لاسطول
البحر الاسود الروسي تعرض لهاجمات متكرره
باسراب من الطائرات المسيره المفخخه اخر
هذه الهجمات كان نهايه ابريل الماضي واحدث
اضرارا جسيمه ادت لاحتراق اربعه صهاريجل
النفط على الساحل الغربي لشبه جزيره القرم
تقع قاعده ساكي الجويه وهي مركز رئيسي
تستخدمه القوات الروسيه لشن هجمات ضد
اوكرانيا في اغسطس الماضي هاجمت طائرات
مسيره القاعده الجويه الروسيه قالت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ان انفجارات عده هزت
القاعده بسبب انفجار لمستودعات الذخيره
لكن الجيش الاوكر
[موسيقى]